loving everything casual perfection
my homage to vin diesel's xxx jacket
i love it welcome back to the red carpet
no
how crazy is this guys it's like deja vu
it feels
so good though i have to say i mean you
know i think it's a lesson for us too i
get so jaded about these things but i'm
emotional i love this tonight yeah it's
really nice
i my mom here and a couple of friends
and we got so excited about dressing up
it was a little over the top
no never too over the top for our first
time back or for you might i add
so you guys when this airs this coverage
of this red carpet tonight
um airs tomorrow we'll literally be one
day before
the 20th anniversary of this franchise
oh wow i didn't know that two decades
charlize
wow i was like 15.
we're going with that i'm gonna be right
with you i was 15 i was a teenager
that's crazy i didn't know that but it
makes sense i mean i feel like they've
been part of our
the fabric of society forever right this
this this family this franchise that's
amazing
and now you have come in and become the
first villain to
be back to back in films welcome back on
that front two bowl
cutting all you were wearing it suck it
jason
you heard that statham but seriously you
know to wear that honor especially as a
female in this franchise like that's
kind of that's a big deal
yeah i can almost guarantee and again
this is the fast and furious franchise
so i
i i want to watch myself because they do
push push the boundaries but i can
almost guarantee that cypher will never
turn and become a good person i i think
we can guarantee on her to
to remain a psychopath i was going to
say i don't think i want to see her
as a good person no we need her in that
lane she's exactly
for sure are your babies impressed at
all about mom and fast cars
or do they just not no my kids are so
not impressed by anything that i do
it's really sad the biggest thing that
we're going through right now is they're
really into dance and i was a dancer
most of my life
so they go to this incredible dance
studio and then when they come home
they'll like dance in the kitchen and
i'll be like oh this is really how you
and they're like mom that's not
i'm like you guys i was a dancer like i
i know this they're not
impressed they don't want to learn
anything from me so no
they're not there yet welcome to
motherhood i know i know right
and finally um this movie is going to
bring people back to the theaters in a
big way
you know number one why should people
see this in the theater and then
you know what is it about that
collective experience of going to the
movies that is just so magical
i think it's been like a question that
we've asked a lot and i think covet is
going to make us fully aware of what
that is and it is that shared experience
it's it is just impossible for us not to
it's
going back to mythology and sitting by
the fireplace and hearing stories
right we have to share that experience
and no matter how great it is to watch
something at home
there's only a certain amount of that
that you can really endure before it
feels like you're not sharing that with
somebody else so i think this movie
could not come out at a better time
it's the narrative of the story is so
family driven and the idea of like
sharing this experience with other
people
it just feels very fitting they're gonna
kill me if i don't ask who the jacket is
by christian dior love
yes have a great time tonight so good to
see your face